bonjour bonjour es-tu ici
pour affaires ou pour le plaisir sais-
tu pourquoi tu es ici
oui
et il sait
faire ou ne
pas non
es-tu prêt à faire une banane heureuse
suce-la
je suis ici pour battre le prochain gros  star du porno
hé je suis venu [ __ ] la merde je vois
trop je veux trop
fille sexy c'est la nouvelle fille qui parle
quelle est la fille qui parle ils sont comme les
a-listers du porno
décroche le téléphone qui est assez vieux pour
pleurer et appeler mon  bluff
je vais être une oratrice tes
réseaux sociaux sont assez petits tu n'as pas de
base de fans mais
tu ne peux pas parler donne moi juste une petite
tape et ça veut dire relax ouais
elle ne peut certainement pas t'aider bien euh
tout le monde va  Je veux te réserver
pour de la merde de plus en plus folle
[Musique]
lécher mes [ __ ] de chaussures
tu ne veux rien voir d'autre à
la à part un [ __ ] de plateau porno pas si
tordu d'aigle personne ne touche mes petites
filles comme ça c'est vraiment foutu
[Musique  ]
pourquoi n'aimes-tu pas faire quelque chose de
mieux dans ta vie et essayer d'être un
chanteur
j'adore la [ __ ]
[Musique]
toi